hey guys so a number of you have been
requesting a cold fusion podcast for a
while now and I think it's finally time
for it to be up and running the podcast
is now live on iTunes Google podcast
Spotify and stitcher so here's the plan
the episodes right now are starting off
with the audio versions of episodes here
on YouTube and then later on the plan is
to have listeners submitted topics and
questions and finally I'd like to have
discussions with you guys
cold fusion subscribers particularly if
those who are experts in technical
fields as well as other experts within
industry my hope is that this will
generate insightful discussion about
topics which are relevant to our modern
world or topics that are just plain
interesting if you want to check out the
cold fusion podcast now can do so and
subscribe to be in the loop about what's
coming up I'll leave links to the
podcast below also feel free to check
out the last episode here on YouTube on
the threats of automation and the pros
and cons of universal basic income the
most popular idea for dealing with the
problem it generated some interesting
debate anyway that's it for now just
wanted to announce this thanks for
watching this has been - go go and I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
you